salut à tous une petite vidéo
informative pour vous annoncer la sortie
de la deuxième chaîne Joueur du Grenier
comme prévu qui s'appellera Joueur du
Grenier
gaming 2 non c'est Bazar du grenier sur
cette chaîne vous pourrez retrouver tout
un tas de concepts et de vidéos qu'on ne
pourrait pas mettre sur la chaîne
principale comme on l'avait dit
précédemment dans la FAQ ben la chaîne
principale joueurs du grenier sert
quasiment exclusivement à proposer ben
joueur du grenier ou papier grenier donc
si on voulait proposer d'autres trucs et
ben il fallait le faire ailleurs alors
rassurez-vous ça ne veut absolument pas
dire qu'on va délaisser la chaîne
principale les vidéos sorties IR on
toujours chaque mois et à
l'heure les émissions joueurs du grenier
et Papi grenier resteront toujours notre
priorité cette seconde chaîne on s'y
consacre uniquement sur notre temps
libre sur cette chaîne évidemment ça
sera à la cool à l'arrache bon
évidemment il y aura des vidéos beaucoup
plus simples que sur la chaîne Joueur du
Grenier on se servira de cette chaîne
pour proposer par exemple des
rediffusions de nos streams ou alors
faire des Let's Play sur des bons jeux
qu'on aime bien à gouche à droite on y
va une émission qui s'appellera jeux en
vra et je vous montrerai des jeux
auquels je joue çaa semessemblera un
mini test rythmé et assez court je
pourrais aussi vous proposer une
émission de cinéma où je pourrais parler
de films que j'ai aimé que j'ai pas aimé
des films qu'il faut aller voir aussi
Nooch ou ne pas les voir et de manière
drôle
aussi parce que je suis desopilant une
émission sur les jeux de rolles papier
qui s'appelle aventure ça sera une
partie de jeux de rôle sur table mise en
scène cette émission d'ailleurs on la
fera avec Bob Lennon crrain Seb et
moi-même et ça sera aussi avec cette
émission qu'on ouvrira la chaîne mardi
prochain à 20h avec les épisodes 0 et 1
d'aventure et puis plus simplement au
fur et à mesure on ajoutera d'autres
trucs genre les annonces de convention
on pourra mettre des bêtisiers on pourra
mettre des FAQ aussi enfin voilà c'est
la chaîne expérimentale donc on pourra
se faire plaisir et vous proposer
d'autres trucs vous pouvez nous soutenir
en vous abonnant à cette seconde chaîne
en cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît en
tout cas on espère que cette seconde
chaîne vous plaira on espère que vous
serez nombreux à venir y jeter un œil et
merci beaucoup d'avance et pour être sûr
que vous abonn la musique ne s'arrêtera
que lorsque vous aurez cliqué
a PZA with
peeron on the second day of CHRM the
turtles to me two comic books and the
PZA with
[Musique]
peeron on the third day of CHRM the
turtles gave to me three skatebard two
comic books and a pizza with
peeron on the day of christm the to me
man
[Musique]